un sentiment d'apaisement en fait à la
sortie des salles et le public et est
très heureux d'avoir vu ce film
je veux juste ajouter pas part au débat
d'accord simplement ces thématiques la
font réfléchir beaucoup plus largement à
ce que c'est que le vivre ensemble
ce à quoi servent les lois et à ce
qu'ils font une cohésion d'un peuple qui
sait vivre ensemble il me semble que les
lois ne sont pas forcément fait pour me
faire plaisir car documentaire que pour
aider quelques dizaines ou quelques
centaines de personnes c'est ce qui m'a
été donnée pour moi d'apprendre à titre
personnel justement pourrait dépenser
téléspecateurs je précise que votre
documentaire les yeux ouverts sera donc
diffusée sur un trentaine public sénat
dans les prochains jours merci messieurs
on va voir à présent la question de
figueroa notre partenaire le figaro.fr
poser tous les jours à nos internautes
la voici maladie incurable et soins
palliatifs sont ils la meilleure
solution
oui à 49% non à 37% voici pour le voici
pour le choix des internautes merci
messieurs on va rejoindre tout de suite
évidemment la séance et les discussions
autour de la légalisation de
l'euthanasie avec delphine gérard oui
merci sonia donc nous allons tout de
suite bien entendu prendre la direction
de l'hémicycle où la discussion de
l'examen de cette proposition de loi a
débuté il ya à peu près une demi heure
c'est xavier bertrand le ministre de la
santé qui est en séance pour défendre la
position du gouvernement
je vous propose tout de suite de
l'écouté très bonne séance à bout
et pavie dans la suite de la discussion
générale sur lesquels les soins
palliatifs permettent d'agir
efficacement chacun s'accorde à le
reconnaître
soulager la douleur physique accompagner
la peur de la solitude et prendre en
compte aussi prendre en compte aussi le
sentiment d'indignité
c'est à dire ce sentiment terrible de ne
plus servir à rien de peser sur son
entourage d'être une charge pour la
société et la l'accompagnement
psychologique mais aussi bien sur
l'accompagnement de la famille et des
proches jouent un rôle essentiel
les soins palliatifs ça faire cela ce
dont nous avons besoin aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas d'une loi qui autorise à
donner la mort c'est d'une application
de la loi actuelle cette loi relative
aux droits des malades et à la fin de
vie du 22 avril 2005
je les dis je les dis j'aurais
certainement des éléments de réponse
président fischer sur ce point je les
dis plus de deux tiers des français
ignorent qu'il existe cette loi cette
loi porte pourtant des réponses adaptées
aux situations de fin de vie elle
proscrit
elle proscrit l'obstination
déraisonnable de choix elle autorise la
limitation ou l'arrêt de traitement
ainsi que l'usagé des antalgiques cette
loi reconnaît également le droit du
malade à demander une limitation ou un
arrêt de traitement
les choses sont dites dans la loi les
shows sont prévues dans la loi
et lorsque le malade est inconscient là
la loi dispose que sa volonté doit être
respectée telle qu'elle a été exprimée
préalablement ou au travers le
témoignage de sa famille et de ses
proches
la volonté du gouvernement est donc
clair développer les soins palliatifs et
refuser l'acharnement thérapeutique
nous allons donc poursuivre le programme
de développement des soins palliatifs et
la prise en charge des personnes en fin
de vie
le prénom de la république en a fait une
priorité
une priorité absolue en juin 2008 le
pilotage de ce programme le pilotage de
ce programme de développement des soins
palliatifs
si au moins sur un sujet comme celui-ci
nous nous écoutions si au moins sur un
sujet comme celui-ci nous nous écoutions
le pilotage de ce programme de
développement des soins palliatifs a été
confiée au docteur régis aubry
spécialiste reconnu dans la prise en
charge palliative
est il prévu en particulier d'augmenter
en quatre ans de 2008 à 2012
significativement le nombre de patients
en fin de vie pris en charge et de créer
mille deux cents nouveaux lits de soins
palliatifs dans les hôpitaux
ce dernier objectif nous sommes en train
de l'atteindre et notamment en
garantissant pardon en fléchant des
crédits pour la mise en place des soins
palliatifs dans les établissements de
santé pour qu on n'attribue pas des
crédits qui au dernier moment pour des
raisons de priorités locales seraient
attribués à d'autres priorités
c'est l'engagement que je dois prendre
en tant que ministre de la santé et je
vois sur le rapporteur que c'est là
aussi l'un des enjeux de dire les soins
palliatifs vous en parler d'accord il
faut permettre qu'ils soient une réalité
nos établissements j'ai bien conscience
au moment où nous avons ce débat que
c'est sur ce point que nous devons
prendre des engagements renforcés
il ne s'agit pas pour moi de dire qu'il
y aura mille deux cents nouveaux lits
c'est de faire en sorte pour les
patients des familles concernées qu'il y
ait ces 1200 nouveaux lits le
gouvernement s'est également engagé à
appliquer les recommandations issues du
rapport de jean leonetti en décembre
2008 sur la fin de vie ainsi par exemple
la loi du 2 mars 2010 institue et
l'allocation d'accompagnement d'une
personne en fin de vie est important
pour certains aidants comme nous devons
aussi approfondir le débat sur la prise
en charge de la fin de vie je compte sur
l'observatoire national de la fin de vie
il a été créé en février 2010 pour
promouvoir les travaux de recherche sur
l'euthanasie sur le suicide assisté
certaines études vous le savez sont
d'ailleurs déjà en cours et nous en
aurons les résultats quand en septembre
prochain pendant des années dans les
mois qui viennent nous devons notamment
analyser attentivement les expériences
étrangères
en belgique par exemple en belgique
cette pratique est légale mais seulement
53% des cas d'euthanasie sont rapportés
au comité de contrôle
cela veut donc dire que 47% des états
d'asie sont pratiquées en dehors du
cadre légal
chacun doit donc bien mesurer les
risques encourus si nous adoptions un
dispositif qui serait moins précis que
celui qui est en vigueur aujourd'hui en
belgique
et les exemples que nous avons notamment
sur la belgique
les études dont nous disposons sont des
études indépendantes fait dans d'autres
pays qui permettent de porter un regard
objectif sur ce qui s'est passé dans les
pays d'europe qui ont changé leur
système n'ont pas de prise en charge de
la fin de vie mais le système de fin de
vie mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous en avons bien conscience d'ailleurs
les textes
ce sont avant tout des situations de
souffrance insupportable pour les
malades
insupportable pour leurs proches dont il
est question les témoignages vous êtes
élue je suis élu également nous en avons
reçu de nombreux et bien évidemment bien
souvent sur les témoignages que l'on
porte dans sa chair ou les témoignages
que l'on se dit qu'on aura un jour a
rapporté pour soi même et pour ses
proches
je pense qu'il est important aussi ce
soir de porter une réelle pédagogie sur
ce sujet c'est marie de hennezel ils
disaient les propositions de loi sur
l'euthanasie fleurissent sur le terreau
de la méconnaissance ici vous connaissez
le dossier vous même ce le rapporteur
vous connaissez ce dossier depuis
longtemps voilà pourquoi je respecte
même si je ne partage pas la position
que vous avez eue mais nous devons bien
entendu entendre avec respect les
arguments de chacun et ne pas nous en
tenir à des idées toutes faites mais
quelles que soient nos convictions
quelles que soient nos convictions pour
un débat à mon sens ce qui n'a rien de
partisan je me souviens d'ailleurs je me
souviens d'ailleurs qu'avant la loi
leonetti il ya vu un travail en commun
de deux parlementaires à l'époque
nadine morano et gaëtan gorce qui
montrait bien qu'il s'agissait d'un
sujet qui dépassait qui transcendait les
clivages
quelles que soient nos convictions je
pense que nous devons choisir de
privilégier la réflexion et la
conviction plutôt que l'émotion et la
précipitation
notre responsabilité est de mieux
répondre aux souffrances c'est de
protéger les personnes vulnérables et
non de donner volontairement là
à autrui c'est ainsi à mon sens que nous
répondrons de la façon la plus juste et
surtout la plus digne au difficile débat
sur la fin de vie
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
ministre
quitte à vis passionnés
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à madame valérie létard le
groupe de l'union centriste pour six
minutes
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
avant d'entrer dans le vif du débat
permettez moi de vous dire à quel point
j'apprécie d'avoir rejoint les rangs de
la commission des affaires sociales sur
les trois propositions de loi qui ont
été soumises à discussion commune notre
débat en commission a été et je le tiens
à le dire respectueux des personnes et
des convictions
merci à notre présidente madame dini qui
a su maintenir cet esprit de sérieuses
réflexions les législateurs que nous
sommes avons pleinement conscience que
ce sujet est grave et qu'il m'aime mêle
intimement l'éthique le juridique et le
sociétal permettez moi également de
saluer avec beaucoup d'émotion le
travail tout à fait remarquable effectué
par le président à bout dont le jugement
perspicace la capacité d'écouté le souci
d'apporter des solutions mesurer vont à
n'en pas douter nous manquer mais il
reste la réflexion engagée par le groupe
de travail sur la fin de vie
constituée à son initiative ce groupe a
apporté une contribution très riche à ce
débat et je tenais à l'en remercier pour
la justesse des pistes qu'il a tracée
enfin permettez moi également de saluer
la qualité du travail de notre
rapporteur jean pierre godefroy
quelle que soit l'issue finale de nos
débats sa contribution pour faire
avancer la prise en compte de la fin de
vie dans un sens toujours plus
respectueux des volontés exprimées par
les patients ajoute une pierre utiles à
notre réflexion commune mais revenons à
la question de l'aide médicalisée à
mourir ce débat et je le crois
nécessaire et c'est tout à l'honneur de
notre haute assemblée d'avoir eu le
courage de l'ouvrir cette question n'a
pas surgi par hasard dans le débat elle
s'est développée avec les progrès
baignable de la médecine une vision
parfois très technicienne de celle ci
s'est avérée de plus en plus inadapté au
moment de la fin de vie ou la
possibilité de soigner pour guérir
n'existe plus
la médecine a dû s'adapter la mort
survient désormais le plus souvent au
terme d'un long processus de souffrance
et de déchéance physique parfois dans
une détresse psychique et morale qui
atteint le malade comme ses proches qui
ne connaît l'état d'épuisement des
accompagnants au point que nous avons
choisi à juste titre d'instaurer un
congé spécifique et depuis la loi du 2
mars 2010 de le rémunérer
grâce à une allocation d'accompagnement
de la personne en fin de vie
faisant suite à plusieurs textes dont
celui initié par notre collègue lucien
neuwirth ce qui avait été un précurseur
la loi du 22 avril 2005 dite loi
leonetti s'est attaché à stopper
l'acharnement thérapeutique vous l'avez
rappelé à mieux informer le patient à
mieux prendre en compte aussi sa volonté
et à promouvoir un accès généralisé aux
soins palliatifs
cette loi constitue une avancée majeure
et puise rappelait d'ailleurs qu'en 2005
l'ensemble du groupe de l'union
centriste avait apporté son soutien ce
texte mais que constate-t-on
six ans après l'adoption de cette loi
que malgré le volontarisme du
gouvernement et les plans successifs
pour augmenter le nombre des places dans
les services de soins palliatifs
beaucoup de malades et de leurs proches
ne trouve ni l'information dont ils ont
besoin
ni une prise en charge adaptée trop peu
sont entourés de personnels formés et
capables de leur apporter le réconfort
si shipcom physiques dont ils ont
cruellement besoin
on constate un trop grand décalage entre
l'affichage de création de places
nouvelles et dans les faits
des moyens trop insuffisant fléché
spécifiquement sur les soins palliatifs
et monsieur le ministre vous l'a rêvé
rappeler et je partage votre en bas et
votre engagement
je pense que si effectivement le
gouvernement fait un effort de fléchage
des crédits pour les soins palliatifs
il faut vraiment être vigilant à
l'avenir j'ai bien entendu votre message
parce que cela ne se perdent pas dans
les dotations globales donner aux
hôpitaux qui pourrait être tenté
quelques fois parce qu'il ya des
urgences de toute nature de les utiliser
à d'autres choses quand on connaît la
nécessité d'être présent à ce rendez
vous et c'est très important de ne pas
oublier cet aspect des choses
alors on constate aussi que trop peu de
professionnels se sont approprié cette
loi dans toutes ses dimensions
si ce débat que beaucoup ont choisi de
renommée législation de l'euthanasie
perdure c'est bien le signe que les
progrès accomplis n'ont pas encore
permis de prendre en compte toutes les
détresses de la fin de vie pour ma part
je ne crois pas que la commission des
affaires sociales en examinant ces
propositions de loin et choisi d'ouvrir
un débat sur l'euthanasie en général
notre commission c'est juste rendu à
l'évidence que certaines situations
n'était pas réglée par les dispositions
de la loi leonetti en instaurant la
généralisation des soins palliatifs
nous avons en même temps reconnu que le
patient en fin de vie avait droit à la
parole et qu'il était acteur de sa vie
jusqu'au bout cela suppose que dans ces
situations la décision n'est plus
seulement aux mains des soignants cette
décision elle se partage
il y à là à n'en pas douter une
véritable évolution culturelle qui doit
faire son chemin
un patient qui acceptent d'être
davantage maître de son destin
un soignant attentif à la volonté
exprimée dû soigner
voilà pour moi les termes du débat et
cela mérite que l'on en parle en évitant
les crispations en évitant les anathèmes
en évitant les caricatures bien
évidemment de part et d'autre oui donc
au débat parce que le point sur lequel
nous nous rassemblons tous c'est que
nous voulons collectivement que notre
société permet aux personnes de bien
mourir et que la mort cesse d'être
escamoté mais puisse au contraire être
partagées accompagné réintégrer dans le
processus de la vie dont elle ne
constitue que l'ultime étape
telles sont les raisons qui m'ont
incitée tout comme nicolas à bout avec
lequel j'ai partagé le même avis a voté
l'article 1er de la présente proposition
de loi en commission en vo dans cet
article 1er j'ai souhaité que l'on
reconnaisse les zones grises que notre
législation à laisser perdurer
notre collègue sylvie desmarescaux que
nous à qui nous a proposé hier soir de
visionner un témoignage sur le
fonctionnement de la maison médicale
jeanne garnier
dans ce film les yeux ouverts on nous
montre une séquence où une équipe
médicale choisi à la demande d'un malade
d'interrompre un traitement entraînant
trois jours plus tard le décès de la
personne n'est ce pas si l'on veut bien
y réfléchir une certaine forme
d'assistance à mourir
celle ci est légal d'autres ne le serait
pas mais pour moi la limite doivent nous
interpeller
elle appelle la réflexion et le débat
mais pour qu'il y ait débat encore
faut-il savoir quelle est exactement la
situation aujourd'hui en france nous
avons besoin d'un état des lieux qui
permettent de connaître quelles sont les
pratiques
quelles sont les dérives quelle
conséquence nous serions en droit
d'attendre d'un changement de la
législation à ce moment là il faut
reconnaître que nous ne disposons pas
d'une photographie précise de que ce
qu'il se passe
l'observatoire de la fin de vie créée en
2010 seulement ne dispose pas encore des
données chine en tant que chargé
c'est pour cela que bien évidemment nous
avons besoin d'études complémentaires
pour pouvoir nous positionner et avant
de pouvoir nous trouver en situation
d'adopter un texte comme celui là
aujourd'hui rien n'est réglé et c'est
vrai qu'il nous faut maintenant parce
que bien évidemment un certain nombre de
situations demande effectivement d'être
up
il faut conclure s'il vous plaît alors
si vous le permettez puisque je ne peux
pas sur un sujet aussi difficile
aller au bout de mon propos et le
démontrer excusez moi si vous le
permettez je vais donc donner deux
phrase de conclusion puisque je ne peux
pas aller jusqu'au bout de mon propos
est simplement vous dire que il y as
place à la réflexion pour que les
prescriptions d'une telle loi apporte
toutes les garanties face à des
situations d'infini fragilité ou doivent
se combiner protection et respect des
volontés de la personne les débats
autour de la loi léonetti montre bien
qu'il reste des situations auxquelles la
législation actuelle ne répond pas
complètement
tôt ou tard cette loi devra être
complétée le mérite du sénat et d'ouvrir
le débat
nous devrons continuer à le faire vivre
jusqu'à ce que se dégage un consensus
suffisamment fort c'est la raison pour
laquelle bien que favorable au principe
je m'abstiendrai personnellement sur ce
texte
tout simplement tout simplement encore
une fois parce que je pense que sur ce
sujet il nous faut encore non seulement
compléter et faire en sorte que la loi
leonetti soient mieux appliquées
mais encore une fois la compléter parce
que nombre de situations aujourd'hui ne
sont pas réglés merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame sylvie
desmarescaux pour le groupe des non
inscrits et pour 3 minutes
posément
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues le débat
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui n'est pas
loin s'en faut le premier sur la fin de
vie mais parce qu'il nous renvoie à nos
convictions profondes à notre approche
personnelle et je dirais même viscéral
de la vie et de la mort
il reste toujours aussi vif et lourd de
sens pour chacun d'entre nous les heures
que nous consacrons à ce thème difficile
de la fin de vie sont utiles et ce ne
sont pas sans nous rappeler ce que
albert camus appelé l'absurdité de la
condition humaine
car finalement ce qu'il y a de plus
révoltant dans la vie c'est la mort la
nôtre évidemment mais aussi et peut-être
surtout celle de nos proches
mais en dehors de toute considération
religieuse c'est bien la conscience de
cette mort inéluctable qui permet aussi
à l'homme de goûter les moments présents
les auteurs des propositions de lois
réunis en un seul texte veulent
légaliser une procédure d'euthanasie
prônant des principes de respect et de
dignité de la personne
à mon sens cette approche de la fin de
vie n'est ni complète ni sereine rendre
effectif équitable l'accès aux moyens
antalgiques accompagner les personnes et
leurs proches lorsque la vie arrive à
son terme et favoriser le développement
des soins palliatifs me semble en effet
davantage coïncidé avec une approche
globale de la fin de vie nous avons
autour de ces défis chers collègues un
combat profondément politique à mener
une vision du vivre ensemble à défendre
et à faire progresser
tell me semblent être les engagements à
tenir que nous devons en tant que
législateur à nos concitoyens la loi du
22 avril 2005 relative aux droits des
malades et à la fin de vie a permis
chacun en convient de réelles avancées
en consacrant notamment le principe
d'obstination déraisonnable et le droit
au refus d'un traitement en 2005
l'hypothèse d'une légalisation de
l'euthanasie
c'est à dire l'injection de substances
létales visant délibérément à faire
mourir avait été écarté parce qu'elle
est constitutive du socle sur lequel
notre société repose cette différence
éthique fondamentale entre le fait de
donner la mort et celui de ne pas
l'empêcher à tout prix doit être
maintenu notre rôle de législateur sera
rempli si nous appréhendons le débat sur
la fin de vie de façon générale et non
pas au travers du seul prisme de
l'euthanasie ce n'est à mon sens ni le
rôle de la loi ni de notre devoir de
parlementaire de mettre en place sans
connaissance préalable des conséquences
qu'ils emportent des mécanismes
permettant de mettre délibérément un
terme à la vie la vie est un bien trop
précieux
depuis quelques années on voit émerger
les prémices d'une véritable diffusion
de la culture palliative
tout doit être mis en oeuvre pour
continuer à avancer dans cette voie
le développement de l'offre de soins
palliatifs à l'hôpital en vivent dans
les établissements d'accueil pour
personnes âgées ou personnes handicapées
sont effectivement des actions à
poursuivre se tient d'ailleurs ici à
saluer le travail formidable réalisé par
ses équipes auprès des patients et de
leurs familles en termes
d'accompagnement et de soutien
regarde la qualité des soins dispensés
aux patients et à l'accompagnement
proposé aux proches il n'est pas rare de
constater qu'une personne qui demande à
mourir change d'avis quelques jours plus
tard pour beaucoup d'entre vous vous le
savez je les vécu avec ma fille mes
propos ne sont donc pas des paroles
rapportées notre fille est mort dans la
dignité
parce qu'elle a fini sa vie entouré de
personnes convaincues de cette dignité
malgré sa maladie et malgré ses
souffrances pour les raisons que je vous
ai exposé il ne me semble pas que le
débat sur la fin de vie doivent se
résumer à la question de la légalisation
ou don de l'euthanasie en revanche il
doit être appréhendé dans son ensemble
avec toute l'humanité que nous devons au
sujet de plus nous ne disposons nous ne
disposons pas en l'état actuel de
connaissance suffisante pour investir de
façon optimale ce débat
des données factuelles précises
devraient émerger des travaux de
l'observatoire national de la fin de vie
mis en place en septembre dernier
loin de sondages reflétant une qualité
une réalité aléatoire il est également à
mon sens essentiel qu'un débat sociétal
puisse avoir lieu et que les avis des
acteurs du système de soins mais
également des malades eux mêmes soient
connus il ne s'agit d' ignorer ni la
souffrance ni la douleur mais de prendre
le recul nécessaire pour poser les
bonnes questions et y apporter des
réponses certes concret mais aussi et
surtout mesuré vous l'avez compris je ne
voterai pas ce texte
merci château l'oeil la parole est à
monsieur gilbert barbier pour le groupe
r d est ce pour six minutes heure
monsieur le président
sur le président ni ceux des ministres
mes chers collègues le ministre appelée
ya quelques instants que 94 % des
français seraient favorables à une
légalisation de l'euthanasie selon un
sondage ifop réalisé en octobre dernier
ce chiffre se veut convaincant pour
certains mais chacun ici c'est que le
résultat est souvent affaire de
formulation quand on propose la mort
sans souffrance
je suis personnellement surpris que 57
personnes sur les 956 interrogées se
prononcent contre
on a évoqué aussi une miss sondage
opinion way ou 60 % des français
déclarent préférer le développement des
soins palliatifs à la légalisation de
l'euthanasie 52 % estimant même qu'une
telle loi comporterait des risques de
dérives de chers collègues je ne pense
pas qu'on peut sérieusement se fier aux
sondages pour répondre à un problème
aussi complexe est aussi sensible que
celui que rencontre chacun d'entre nous
face à la mort le sujet de nous traitons
aujourd'hui mérite un peu plus de
dignité de respect j'ai entendu par
exemple dans mon département le
président de l'association qui défend
cette loi dénoncée régulièrement les
voleurs de liberté que serait notamment
les médecins parlementaires sourd à la
souffrance de leurs semblables et
partisan de l'acharnement thérapeutique
j'étais médecin je suis parlementaire
je suis opposé à la légalisation de
l'euthanasie
je serai donc qu'un voleur de liberté
soit mais qu'il me soit permis au moins
tu en donner les raisons
en réalité nombre de nos concitoyens
trouve une justification à l'euthanasie
dans une analyse ou une tentative d'
analyse de leur propre mort les sondages
nous d une seule chose tout 5
je ne veux pas souffrir nous sommes à
peu près tous dans cette disposition de
la question posée aujourd'hui
n'est pas celle de notre propre mort
dont freud disait qu'il nous est
absolument impossible de nous la
représenter car toutes les fois que nous
l'essayons nous nous apercevons que nous
y assistons en tant que spectateur et
dans son inconscient
chacun est persuadé de sa propre
immortalité
la question aujourd'hui est de savoir si
la société doit reconnaître un droit à
l'aide active à mourir
soyons clair un droit de tuer au nom de
la dignité du malade et du respect de sa
volonté appelons les choses comme elles
gauter car s'il s'agit bien de cela dans
la proposition de loi qui nous est
présenté au delà des intentions sans
doute sincère au delà des préoccupations
de langage reste le fait que c'est bien
un tiers qui dispose d'une vie qui n'est
pas la sienne fusent dans des
circonstances limitées et avec l'accord
de l'intéressé
c'est pour le moins curieux dans un pays
qui a voté il y a trente ans l'abolition
de la peine de mort je dois dire que
l'expression retenue par les auteurs de
cette proposition assistance médicalisée
permettant par un acte délibéré une mort
rapide et sans douleur ça quelque chose
à mon avis de maladroit war ii glaçant
et peut rappeler des pratiques très
ancienne
ce n'est pas les termes ce n'est pas les
termes assistance médicalisée qui
permettent de s'affranchir de la
violence de l'acte dans une mort douce
simone de beauvoir disait à propos de sa
mère une vieille femme au bout du temps
elle disait n'y a pas de mort naturelle
toute mort est une violence un but bien
qu'athée elle a bien noté la
contradiction essentielle de la
condition humaine même naturel la mort
est un scandale alors en quoi une fin de
vie rapide donné par autrui
garantit-elle une fin de vie calme et
digne l'amalgamme que font certains
entre utah nazis aient droit à mourir
dans la dignité
et d'ailleurs et
acceptable qui s'aviseraient de dénier
ce droit à quiconque
faut-il rappeler que la dignité est un
caractère intrinsèque de toute personne
quelle est la même pour tous elle
n'admet pas de degré selon le philosophe
paul ricoeur cette notion renvoie l'idée
que quelque chose est due à l'être
humain du fait qu'il est humain on veut
respecter la volonté des personnes mais
le soin le souhait d'en finir pour ne
souffrir ni physiquement ni
psychiquement relève d'une forme de
névrose obsessionnelle qui habite chacun
d'entre nous de ne pas avoir à se
trouver face à la mort c'est peut-être
la rançon des avancées techniques mais
c'est aussi comme le disait la
rochefoucauld parce que le soleil ni la
mort ne se peuvent regarder fixement
quoi qu'il en soit ce soit peut varier
en fonction de tel ou tel soulagement
informations événements extérieurs les
malades en fin de vie peuvent vouloir
épargner leurs proches par une demande
qui ne correspond pas forcément à leur
désir profond enfin on croit on aurait
pu croire que ce texte satisfasse les
idéologues voulant sortir de la société
de l'obscurantisme du corps médical et
les c'est l'individu maître de sa
destinée
en fait il n'en est rien il remet encore
la décision finale est le geste de
l'euthanasie sur la responsabilité des
médecins dans une procédure bien
complexe d'ailleurs il appartiendra donc
toujours au delà des lois pour de
respecter ou non le cercle bandits crew
d'hippocrate qui dans sa version
originale a dit je le rappelle
jamais je ne remettrai du poison même si
on me le demande je ne conseillerais pas
d'y recourir
il y à bien d'autres points développés
dans cette discussion
je ne manquerai pas les aborder dans
l'examen des articles en toute
indépendance d'esprit car je ne suis à
la solde de personne
mes chers collègues je respecte et
opinions de chacun d'entre nous dans ces
débats de société
je m'exprime ici en confiance comme je
lé fais par exemple en 1979 en soutenant
simone veil dans son combat pour libé
j'ai ma position ne se veut ferme et ne
se veut pas fermé à toute détresse et
dans la profession croyez moi j'en ai
rencontré la loi leonetti de 2005 et
l'article 37 du code de déontologie
récemment complété condamne
l'obstination déraisonnable der comment
l'utilisation de tous les moyens
nécessaires au soulagement des douleurs
et à l'apaisement des angoisses
terminales ses moyens existent et s'ils
ne sont pas mises en oeuvre c'est par
méconnaissance des dispositions légales
et même de culture palliative
ce n'est pas pour cette raison que
demain il faut autoriser à tuer je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur guy fischer pour le groupe crc
spg aux 15 minutes
je
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues comme
d'autres viennent de l'exprimer je fais
le voeu que le débat qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui soit le plus apaisé possible
que de part et d'autre on évite les
anathèmes les amalgames grossiers les
raccourcis dangereux et que l'on
considère tous les intervenants qui se
succèdent dans la pluralité de leurs
propos de leur intervention et de leurs
convictions pour ce qu'ils sont des
femmes et des hommes qui ont en la
matière des positions personnelles
qu'ils veulent défendre
je voudrais d'ailleurs avant de
commencer remercier chacun des membres
de mon groupe pour avoir durant nos
propres échanges donner corps à ce
principe
je voudrais les en remercier leur dire
que par respect pour celui qu'ils m'ont
témoignée
je comprends leurs questionnements et
leurs doutes et à vous tous mes chers
collègues ainsi qu'à celles et ceux qui
suivent
aujourd'hui nos débats ils sont nombreux
j'en suis certain je voudrais vous dire
qu intervenant devant vous je ne suis
que le porte parole donnée de femmes et
non d'un groupe ou d'un parti qui
partagent en la matière certaines
convictions c'est la raison pour
laquelle je me retrouve dans les
interventions ou les prises de position
de certains de mes collègues du groupe
ump ou de l'union centriste avec qui ou
du groupe socialiste avec qui nous
sommes très souvent en opposition
dès lors qu'il s'agit d'économie de
fiscalité de politique des territoires
ou de droits sociaux
naturellement je me réjouis que la
commission des affaires sociales est
rendue possible et par une majorité
importante
l'examen de cette proposition de loi
texte de consensus issus des trois
propositions de loi initial déposées
l'une par monsieur godefroy et une
partie des membres du groupe socialiste
une autre partie nature alain fouché et
celles que j'ai moi même déposé avec mon
ami françois autain et près de dix huit
autres membres du groupe crc spg
l'adoption par la commission des
affaires sociales de la proposition de
loi que nous sommes appelés à examiner
ce soir un cycle débat qui va suivre ne
sera pas la victoire d'un camp sur un
autre et si nous avons été nombreux à
nous réjouir du sort que la commission
des affaires sociales a réservé aux
textes que nous avions déposé
c'est que d'une part la commission par
son vote n'a pas entravé le droit des
parlementaires à légiférer et que
d'autre part elle a permis que soit
abordé en séance publique un sujet aussi
important pour chacun d'entre nous
quelle que soit notre position mes chers
collègues
c'est en républicain en laïque et en
citoyen que je m'exprime devant vous
pour défendre cette proposition visant à
inscrire dans la loi la possibilité pour
celles et ceux de nos concitoyens qui en
phase avancée ou terminale d'une
affection accidentelle ou pathologique
grave et incurable leur infligeant une
souffrance physique ou psychique ne
pouvant être apaisée ou qu'ils
jugeraient insupportable voudrait en
pleine connaissance de cause bénéficier
dans des conditions très particulières
précise et encadrée d'une assistance
médicalisée permettant par un acte
délibéré une mort plus rapide que celle
pouvant survenir naturellement et sans
douleur et je veux m'en expliquer en
républicain d'abord j'ai comme beaucoup
d'entre vous un attachement à notre
république fondée sur un double pilier
l'état de droit d'une part et les
principes propres à notre république
inscrit sur les frontons de nos écoles
et nos mairies liberté égalité
fraternité
mon engagement au tant que militant
politique et qui se poursuit aujourd'hui
au sénat a toujours été et demeure celle
d'une oeuvre législative respectant nos
concitoyens je devrais même dire les
plaçant au coeur de notre politique
au delà de tout autre intérêt fusse-t-il
commerciaux économiques ou politiques
l'état de droit n'a de sens pour moi que
si les lois servent à l'est
anticipation des femmes et des hommes
une émancipation qui n'est naturellement
pas étrangère à la notion d'égalité
or plus personne n'ignore aujourd'hui
malgré les volontés affichées ou les
déclarations péremptoires de certains
nous ne sommes pas égaux face à la mort
que celle ci surviennent naturellement
ou qu'elle soit choisie car celles et
ceux qui font en pleine connaissance de
cause le choix de mettre médicalement un
terme à leur vie et qui dispose tout à
la fois des informations et des moyens
financiers nécessaires peuvent s'offrir
une mort choisi dans l'un des pays
voisin du nôtre l'autorisant cette
expression de pouvoir s'offrir une mort
choisie
je le sais vous interpelle mais les
témoignages multiples médiatisée aux
plus confidentiels
lattès il y à aujourd'hui d'un côté ceux
qui disposent des possibilités
techniques et matérielles de choisir une
mort digne et rapide et ceux qui plus
démunis ne dispose pas de cette
possibilité
pour cela le droit à une mort choisie
s'apparente plus à un bricolage composé
d'attentes de renoncement de crainte ou
de solutions violentes
ce n'est pas sans nous rappeler la
situation que supportait les femmes
avant l'adoption et dans les conditions
que l'on connaît de la loi du 17 janvier
1975 légalisant l'avortement dit la
veille du nom de la ministre qui l'a
défendue courageusement
souvenons nous qu'avant cette date
l'avortement clandestin n'était pas sans
risque ceux qui les réalisent et
encourait la peine capitale est tout le
monde se souvient du sort terrible qui
fut réservé à marie-louise giro jugé
coupable d'avoir réalisé plusieurs aforp
ans et qui fut décapité en 1943 les
femmes prenaient de leur côté
d'importants risques sanitaires lé décès
post-avortement étaient nombreux 68 ans
plus tard il réside encore d'importantes
similitudes entre les deux situations
même s'il est rare que les personnes qui
optent pour une mort voulons
n'y parviennent pas à quel prix le
font-elles parfois celui d'une
souffrance physique importante et
souvent d'une souffrance morale que l'on
a du mal à mesurer et qui repose
beaucoup sur le sentiment des personnes
voulant être accompagnées dans une mort
qu'elles ont choisi de réaliser un acte
mal perçue par notre société un acte si
abominable aux yeux des autres et de la
loi qu'il est réalisé dans la
clandestinité et le secret et de mort
interdit au point que ceux qui assistent
les personnes désirant mourir encourt
une peine criminelle pour assassinat en
laïque ensuite bien évidemment toutes
celles et tous ceux qui s'opposent
aujourd'hui à ce que leur on légalise
l'assistance médicalisée à mourir ne le
font pas sur des fondements religieux et
à linverse je sais pertinemment qu'il
existe des croyants parmi eux qui plaide
en faveur d'une telle évolution
législative mais je reconnais aussi
parmi les associations qui s'opposent
vigoureusement au droit à mourir dans la
dignité les mêmes associations pro-vie
comme si nous étions de notre côté des
défenseurs de la mort qui s'oppose au
droit à l'avortement
ce sont pour l'aide active à mourir
comme pour l'avortement
les mêmes discours selon lesquelles se
seraient nuire à la dignité humaine que
de décider du moment de sa mort une mort
qui par nature peut être nature dont
peut-être naturel et que les femmes et
les hommes ne pourraient que subir pour
eux les êtres humains sont en quelque
sorte extérieurs à leur mort qui ne peut
être programmé que par celui qu'il ou
qu'elle vénère entendant ses discours je
ne peux que me dire que notre pays
paradoxalement terre des lumières après
avoir été fille aînée de l'église a tout
à gagner à ce que d'autres débats soit
assis sur un principe simple le corps
des hommes n'appartient à aucune entité
autre colom lui même dans le respect des
règles
hop à garantir des protections
collectives une propriété associé au
principe d'inaliénabilité du corps
humain qui a raison précise que l'on ne
peut décider en droit du sort que l'on
veut réserver à son propre corps sans
pouvoir pour autant
au nom d'un principe légitime de
protection des droits collectifs décidé
d'en faire commerce
le corps de chacun est ainsi
exclusivement partagé entre notre
volonté et des droits collectifs cette
question de la propriété abordé ici n'a
pas pour objectif de souligner certaines
divergences
elle nous invite toutefois à se poser
une question supplémentaire que j'estime
être incontournable la législation
relative à la vie doit-elle imposer une
règle générale qui est bonne par
définition ou bien doit-elle intégrer
l'idée d' exception à cette question
c'est en citoyen ou plus thèse ou plutôt
devrais-je dire en homme libre que je
veux répondre
cette proposition de loi ne tend pas à
rang de l'assistance médicalisée à
mourir comme la seule mort possible
elle ne tend pas à la généraliser ou à
l'imposer à toutes et à tous un hack
pour objectif de permettre à celles et
ceux qui le souhaitent de partir
dignement
c'est à dire de partir avant que la
souffrance physique ou psychique ne soit
trop forte
avant que la maladie les dégradations
qui l'accompagnent l'emportent sur
l'humanité des gens
il s'agit comme le précise françois de
closets journaliste et écrivain de frire
et non pas d'imposer un recours contre
cette mauvaise mort non pas en prenant
en charge des destins individuels mais
en permettant aux volontés de chacun de
s'exprimer et d'être respecté certains y
verront une oeuvre libéral au sens
philosophique du terme
j'y vois personnellement une réponse
humaniste et solidaire face à une
situation que l'écrivaine viviane
forestier
parfaitement décrit en ces mots en ces
termes être devenu un lien terrible pour
soi-même un lieu terrible pour soi même
offert une prison et y est maintenu de
force
enfermé sans espoir alors qu'il serait
possible d'en soustraire ceux qui le
demandent ce qu'ils en font le choix
quel est le sort auquel sont condamnés
beaucoup de vivant mes chers collègues
le 20e siècle a été en termes de droits
individuels de conquête des droits de
l'homme sur lui même marqué par la
reconnaissons l'hémicycle du sénat
l'examen de cette proposition de loi va
se poursuivre jusque tard dans la nuit
devant les sénateurs xavier bertrand a
redit son opposition à une légalisation
de l'euthanasie
le ministre de la santé estime que la
loi leonetti sur les soins palliatifs
restent la meilleure solution
valérie létard sénatrice centriste et
ancien secrétaire d'état aux solidarités
a estimé que ce débat était nécessaire
et que le sénat avait le mérite de
l'avoir ouvert
quant à jean pierre godefroy le
rapporteur ps de la commission des
affaires sociales il a rappelé que ce
texte n'était ni politiquement ni
idéologiquement partisans nous
reviendrons bien entendu sur ces débats
demain à partir de 10 heures 30 sur
l'antenne de public sénat
très bonne fin de soirée à tous